in the film Felicity your character give
Skye's character piece of advice which
is not to let fear become his profession
I wondered if either of you had a
particular advice you remember that you
hold dear either for your own lives or
for your work as you've gone along it's
good question it's so easy to listen to
advice but then to actually employ it
into your own life it's so hard
I think someone I remember someone
saying to me never worry
oh it's say say what you I mean always
that thing they say what you feel what
is it it's the end of King Lear and I
say what we feel not what we ought to
say well something that sounds super
pretentious but yeah something it's
something along those lines like no
matter what the situation is don't worry
if you're going to lose your job you
know if you feel something very strongly
then say it I'm felicity of course we
know you so much for all the great indie
films that you might be moving on to a
big superhero blockbuster project with
the amazing spider-man 2 how does it
feel working on something like Lance
uh I really enjoyed it because it was so
different from anything I've ever done
before
and just testing a different thing in
you as an actor cause it's the scale
it's just so enormous but I had a really
good fun time are you looking forward to
everyone seeing you as black cat finally
um well possibly I don't know yeah I
kind of it's um yeah if that happens
that would be wonderful
yes
you